hello everyone if you've been following
what's been going on in the chest world
for the past couple of days you must
have seen the thing everyone is talking
about and by the thing I mean this this
is the new world chess championship logo
that will be used in 2018 afford a match
between Magnus Carlsen and whoever wins
the candidates the match will be held in
London and this is the logo type they
came up with so a lot of people are
saying it's it's just wrong you know it
it kind of reminds you of something that
you'd find in in a Kama Sutra book some
are saying think of the children some
are saying I mean they're saying a lot
of things so I'm very interested what do
you think about the logo have you seen
it before is this the first time you see
it and what do you think is this the way
that you know chest should be presented
in 2018 to the world is what's actually
the message here so I will bring it back
after I show you the game and the game
for this video is actually a game
between the founders of chess comm
between Eric the CEO and the Jay the CTO
they decided to do a reaction video to
this brand new world chess championship
logo I will put a link in the
description below so you can check it
out it's quite an interesting video
they're actually playing a interwined
like the two figures there and with the
chess board in the middle of them in
between them so let's see this game
between Eric and DJ Eric has the white
pieces and he opens with E 4 we have C 5
the Sicilian defence Knight to c3 the
closed Sicilian Knight to c6 g3 g6 and
the bishop to g2 the the fianchetto
variation of the closed Sicilian Bishop
g7 now D 3 d6 pretty symmetrical
position and f4 by Eric 9th to h6
although Knight to f6 was also you know
playable there's nothing wrong with
Knight to f6 but he plays Knight to h6
maybe with some ideas of playing Bishop
to g4 at some point but who knows Knight
to f3
we have castles castles and Bishop to d7
now I'm not going for the more
to Bishop g4 Bishop to e3
quinta c7 and h3 now stopping any
measure of g4 or 9g for ideas rook a to
c8 we have Queen to d2 & e6 now and this
this c6 move is actually a pretty big
blunder as Eric had the option of
playing f5 now this one's a piece there
is no the knight has nowhere to go
Bishop captures on h6 is coming or he
would have to capture the F pawn would
tonight but as I don't think they're
actually playing this game for real this
is just you know I again to include in
the video just to talk about the new
Chess Championship logo so rook a to the
one rook F to e8 and G for now
f5 and now there is a square here that
is freed for the night the night can
retreat if Y decides to push g5 we have
G captures on f5 e captures on f5 and
Knight to g5 now F captures on e4 we
have D captures on e4 and Knights to d4
and there is always option for white to
go Knight to d5 here attacking the Queen
kill you the Queen to be a then push c
3q the knight from before but it seems
that Eric goes by the old saying the
threat is stronger than the execution so
he he waits with this night to be 5 or
d5 will always be an option and he
pushes f5 we have G characters on f5 and
only now does he play Knight to d5 with
the tempo on the Queen and in this
position the CTO of chess comm J said
that he couldn't really maintain that
position anymore that he was falling
back and he played EF captures on e4 he
left the Queen hanging but Eric didn't
capture the Queen he played nice
captures on e4 and as they say in the
article you will find in the description
below they say in this position white
resigned from physical exhaustion so
yeah that's the game played between
founders of chess calm it's quite a
quite an impressive game especially you
know when you're playing in that
position from the thumbnail and you will
also see it in the video in
description below but let's see that
logo one more time so this is the logo
this is a what they plan to use to
present chess in 2018 it's a so you know
Jay Jay and Eric say that it's quite
interesting because now mostly chess is
played you know on screens you know
between people from different sides of
the sides of the planet and this really
makes it you know a person a more
personal game two people come together
they you know join join hands join
ensuring legs they tangle with each
other and they play a nice game so yeah
basically this is what I wanted to ask
you how did you enjoy this logo do you
think it's a bit too much do you like it
do you think it's very modern is it you
know do you also think we should think
about the children or do you have do you
have anything anything other to add to
this this is quite quite an impressive
idea so yeah that's the game that's the
question basically not the game the game
is there
only only to talk about this new world
chess championship logo so yeah I hope
you enjoyed it for those of you who've
seen it for the first time and do share
your thoughts in the comment section
below thank you all for watching and I
will see you soon